sans les assouplissements du
gouvernement cette petite résidence de
30 places n'aurait pas renouveler sa
certification le mois prochain
c'est ce qui aurait fait bien avant sur
place une surveillance 24 heures sur 24
par des gens qualifiés donc à ce moment
là c'est comme trois salaires qui aurait
fallu débourser trop d'argent pour cette
résidence comme pour bien d'autres au
québec
1914 discussions des sorciers on était à
risque d'en perdre jusqu'à 256 un
problème au vu du gouvernement une
résidence qui n'est pas certifié n'est
pas surveillé par l'état québec revoit
donc les normes pour limiter les coûts
rattachés à la certification des normes
exagérée aux yeux de plusieurs
gestionnaires de résidences pour aînés
autonomes
on voulait des tirettes d'urgence dans
votre chambre triple dans votre toilette
dans votre salon on va vous mettre un
gardien qui va cogner à votre porte les
arts on va vous mettre les jeunes et moi
je suis pas mal vieux seconde maladie
désormais les exigences sont établis en
fonction du type de services offerts ont
créé quatre catégories allant de
résidences offrant des services de base
pour les aînés autonomes à des
résidences avec services infirmiers pour
personne en forte perte d'autonomie qui
est d'avoir le même niveau de sécurité
mais de l'adapter en fonction de la
réalité des de la taille des résidences
et des services qui sont offerts dans
les petites résidences pour aînés
autonomes par exemple la surveillance
pourra être exercée par un bénévole
ayant un simple cours de secourisme
c'est un régime à la résidence saint
johnston ça veut dire que j'ai encore
mac os pourra continuer comme bénévole à
assurer la surveillance
québec souhaite que cette fois les
résidents se conformeront aux nouveaux
règlements d'ici un an
ici david gentilles radio canada québec